jay what's up buddy
uh you're muted oh you're muted you
gotta get that line through your mic
bottom of the screen am i coming in
clear thank you
yeah yeah you're good
all right thank you gentlemen so i was
the crazy guy calling in with the one
again awful girl
on again off oh okay yeah yeah that was
uh that was the uh the pencil sharpener
response yes the pencil sharpener yes
don't go and stick your dick in a pencil
sharpener absolutely okay so on again af
again for for six years yeah so what
happened was is i i'm so i'm a i'm a i'm
a lawyer i'm fairly successful i've got
six figures i'm in good shape
uh i don't have fu money but other than
that i think i'm you know checking all
the boxes
and uh so you know
after several years of marriage my wife
who was
another lawyer who happened to be three
or four times
more net worth than i am um you know the
marriage it was sort of like we were a
partnership with children and uh i guess
i had a classic midlife crisis
met this uh beautiful latina woman
and uh
so sort of literally ran off with her
with my motorcycle harley davidson of
course
and um you know the first year i mean
she was exactly like everything you
described about the genuine desire you
know she was looking at me when we took
photos together uh on my 45th birthday
she literally took 45 candles and put
them on a cake
you know she would she
i mean she she came into my frame
um
but the problem is is that
because of my financial situation i
don't i didn't want to get divorced
because uh
are you still married to your ex yes
okay so that's the thing
so this has been on again off again for
five years so she's a devout she claims
i think she is she's very devout
catholic latina she prays every day
you know um burns candles and that sort
of thing
and she was like oh you're you're just
uh being manipulated by your ex-wife so
i'm leaving
and um you know so
uh just
you know i even had my own mother was
like i can see both sides of the story i
didn't want to get divorced yet because
we're still working out issues
financially and between our children
and you know she
just
she would get psycho jealous of my kids
she'd call my ex-wife and ape
and uh she doesn't want to meet two of
my three children
um and frankly i'm so scared of her you
know how latino women are not to be
racist but she was super jealous even of
my children i mean my daughter's cat was
staying at my place
and she got so jealous of the cat when i
was petting the cat like she threw the
cat off the couch one time
um
but uh so what so why are we even having
this conversation dude like you know why
is it like because she's hot she's
pretty and she lets you touch her
boobies like why like why are you
putting up with this is that an answer
is that a question where the answers
contained within the question
maybe it is maybe it's so obvious
i'm i'm always blown away by like the
level of like dude that like lawyer
obviously like my ex-wife's lawyer so i
know what they have to go through to get
that degree and like work that job and
that sort of [ __ ] so it's like you know
like you're a smart guy
and
you see red flags
they're going in a box that says this is
a box of red flags and you still want to
hang out with the red flags anyway right
like it's like she's telling you what
she's about right
i mean you've got to be able to do
better i mean you got to be able to hold
yourself to higher standards is really
what it just boils down to right like
why would you invite this crazy [ __ ]
into your life like you already have a
ex wife you've got kids that you're
trying to raise how old are the kids
um so i've got a daughter that's uh 23
and she's on her way to being a
successful lawyer okay so
seven yeah she's seven she's a son who's
18 who's off at business school yeah and
her daughter is 11. and um
i've been i haven't even introduced her
my younger children uh
just my older uh daughter and she she
does sort of think she's a bit crazy
but here's the thing okay
call me crazy but she definitely had
genuine desire for me and one of the red
flags she talked about was daddy issues
and she has an extremely good
relationship with her father
who cares who cares man she's she's like
she's already told you what what she's
all about with even the red flags that
you've talked about right now i'm sure
there's dozens more you know the years
haven't gotten to or you don't want to
talk about go ahead here's here's the
major thing right is that from all over
well from her perspective right um she
is always going to be that mistress
because your time and attention is
devoted elsewhere predominantly to your
ex-wife but mostly mostly even though
that's going away it's like to your
children so in her eyes you're always
going to be that like secondary mistress
right and the
girls they want to be they want to be
number one right they want to be that
number one spot of attention of intimacy
uh so i'm
52 and she's 40 about 45 or so 47 kids
she has a one son who's 19 years old her
father the father of her son is uh in
germany and he's a pretty much a
hardcore alcoholic sits around all day
and drinks beer
but
sorry well she chose him as a father i
mean i'm pretty sure she did that when
she you know
had a kid with him so i mean it's not
there's no real clear like pathway
because again best case scenario right
if you finish finalize your divorce with
your ex and then you get with her you
still have your children and you have
your children for life if she's still
jealous of those
best case scenario you're still with
this girl that's always going to be dude
she's jealous of your daughter's cat
yeah
[Laughter]
all right
like does that sound weird when i say it
back to you like my girlfriend is
jealous just two days ago she flicked
the cat in the nose you know
dude any any any human being that's like
abusive to an animal and i don't even
like cats but that's serial killer [ __ ]
yeah like it's like [ __ ] up [ __ ] like
that's bunny boiler stuff right like
you're gonna come home and find a cat in
the pot one day
yeah so i mean
look at your best case scenario right
best case upside scenario the biggest
issue right you're still jealous of your
your affection and your relationship
with your kids that's not going anywhere
so best case scenario you still have to
deal with this exact same scenario that
you have even if when your divorce is
finalized or whatever so there is no
real best case scenario upside for you
you're you're probably going to make out
okay with your divorce because she does
better than you but generally speaking
like you know i'm guessing she probably
doesn't make as much money as you this
latino she's um she's unemployable
and
no i i even i've paid for her training
to become a uh
medical pedicurist oh she sucks doesn't
want to go to class even no she's really
good at hanging out with the apartment
and talking to her friends
dude
come on man you're smarter than this
you're way smarter than this
okay do not do not do that all right
final question before how about this um
is it is it's i got a buddy of mine he's
a triathlete triathlete he's very
successful
and a few years ago i was at a a a
dinner party
and he's probably you know 60 years old
he's got some gray hair
and he comes up to me and he goes hello
this is my girlfriend not my daughter
and she was like this 24 year old
beautiful ukrainian and he goes and
because the guy's still married so
here's the thing i'm wondering guys how
crazy is this okay marriage is an
unconscionable contract but
in my current situation
because my current wife is actually
quite wealthy and i actually could
from a financial point of view staying
with her even if we're separated one day
i could hit the jackpot
um
how strange is that to like stay married
for financial reasons and in a certain
sense it's good for the children because
we're not legally divorced i don't know
um
uh
well this is not creating trauma and my
daughter for my first marriage can still
stay at the house with my daughter from
my current marriage
okay i've been married twice
yeah i've been married twice that's
right and you're talking about doing it
a third time no no no no actually rich
one of the
one of the things burned in my brain is
the marriage is an unconscionable
contract okay so i mean like you're not
that makes a lot of sense but i mean
like no but i mean like you like the
idea of a hot young ukrainian bride
they're on sale right now by the way
there's lots of refugees out there well
no i'm giving no not that i'm into
ukrainian young brides i'm talking about
my my uh elderly friend here who yeah he
said he stayed married for financial
reasons i mean yeah that's what i'm
that's the question have you okay so in
your experience okay to that question i
mean you're talking about should i make
myself my own mental point of origin and
if
staying married to your wife for the
kids for financial reasons for dealing
with the assets or whatever i mean
you're talking about
untying this over here to invite
a crazy [ __ ] that doesn't work and
doesn't want to work into your life that
flicks your cat's nose right like
i mean you've got like even though
you're not with your wife you've got a
family with her and you have assets that
you've built together i've seen people
like
you know
basically split up the family and they
keep the matrimonial assets you know
together just for the sake of the estate
and the kids because
it just makes better sense like if
you're going to go and get remarried to
another check and then you've got all
the stuff to deal with the estate and
all that sort of stuff and if she's
still on title you know like you've got
a chalet you've got a cottage you've got
a home you've got a condo down at the
beach sort of thing like if you've built
a life like this and there's an
ecosystem then it if it makes better
sense for you guys logically like on
paper like from a legal perspective to
maintain that but your marriage is no
longer a marriage who cares and who
cares what she thinks you know if she's
like oh you're still married or whatever
it's like well it's on paper but
we don't that's what i said a thousand
times it's paper and she was like no no
no i can't stand it or i mean again i'll
tell you why it's because she's 45 she's
old she knows that her eggs are dried up
she has no other value to any other man
so she has to lock you down she hasn't
locked her down right she's got nothing
going on in her world right she doesn't
have a [ __ ] job she doesn't want to
work she sees this like lottery ticket
you
and it's like if she can un untether you
from that life and then she can get her
meat hooks into you she's taken care of
yeah she doesn't give a [ __ ] about you i
mean she she's flicking your kid's cat's
nose dude
wilson uh yeah she cares more about the
potential investment in protecting like
her lifestyle being funded than actually
you you know well she even said that she
goes i need more security good [ __ ] off
then yeah find some other guy got more
security yeah yeah
all right so here's what i'm thinking
about i'm thinking about going for a
woman closer to my age and closer to my
career path
you know and uh not playing with the
younger have you have you women have you
read my book
uh yes i have i haven't read it twice
but i i have read it so go find hundreds
yeah like you know for a guy like you i
you've already got a family you've
already got kids so
basically what what is it you're looking
for is intimacy companionship friendship
you know if you can find that too as
well compliments your life all that sort
of stuff yeah exactly as soon as you
deal with women while you're dating that
violate any of your basic rules it's out
i don't care if she's a hot latino with
a fat ass it doesn't matter
it doesn't like none of that stuff
matters dude like you don't need any of
that headache any of that chaos in your
life
you already know
the thirties
over looking for a 50 year old broad 28
28 to 32.
well whatever 25 35 it doesn't matter
like as long as she's not complicating
your life the way that this one is yeah
yeah i think
and it's and it's hard and fast like you
know she's not looking to
to lock herself in your life she's not
looking for a marriage so i mean you
might find that a 28 year old hottie
that wants nothing to do with anything
else but just to friends with benefits
maybe that works it might be a 38 year
old chick that's divorced that divorce
raped her husband has more money than
god has more money than you but digs
your vibe you're professional you look
like good arm candy because you guys can
go to professional events together hey
here's jay
jay toenail jay tony o'neal o'neil
o'neil
j
j toenail the lawyer whatever uh you
know here's my arm candy you're going to
look good on her arm and she's probably
never going to want to marry you anyway
because she's already got her [ __ ] and
she knows that if she marries you then
she's going to expose her wealth to you
sort of thing so i mean like you could
look at it from different angles but
yeah all that it boils down to is do
what's best for you that's what mental
point of origin means right you don't
you don't sacrifice stop stop playing
captain save a hoe okay like this is
what you're doing with this
latino check playing captain save hoe
let let her live with her bad choices
from her lifestyle you have your life
you have your kids to raise you have
your wealth to protect
do that i mean like
what does your ex-wife say about all
this i'm sure she's had a you know
opinion about you
she i mean it's really weird she's like
don't ask don't tell you know i live on
the other side of town
and i've been living with her on again
and off again for six years in between
that i was dating other women yeah um
you know following your advice and you
know other gentleman's advice roller
tomassi i really got a lot out of that
you know i've been hitting the gym hard
i've i mean i'm not arnold
schwarzenegger i got the v-shape going i
got harley-davidson i play drums in a
band
um you know i guess
the only thing i'm missing out of the
checklist is the fu money i'm working on
that but not quite there okay and uh you
know so i've got options
um and i'm very familiar with the term
one itis
uh i've had one itis probably six times
in my though there you go you know i've
learned well i mean you've got it right
now for this trick because i mean you're
making a lot of excuses for her bad
behaviors right yeah and again look at
your best scenario with this girl like
your best friend no it's not that great
well that's the psycho
the psych psycho thing is i'm wondering
if i'm the problem not her you are a
problem yeah
well you're enabling it right because
it's like she's doing it
she's a separate problem that shouldn't
be your problem but the problem that you
have is that you don't have high enough
standards for yourself
in what it is that you're willing to
tolerate with a good woman i mean the
show topic is what is a good woman this
woman's not a good woman and you're
asking about marrying her in the super
chat and it's like
might as well stick your dick in a
pencil sharpener while you're at it too
right
yeah because i mean the thing is right
you can you can walk like this is a
restaurant right that keeps serving you
bad food it's burnt it's giving you
making you sick the chicken's right
going to the damn restaurant you can get
up and leave that restaurant you don't
have to eat there there's a lot of other
restaurants around the street
so you know why would you sit there and
continuously stay at this restaurant and
then
contemplate like oh maybe i should like
be an active investor in this restaurant
start buying shares in it why would you
do that yeah
all right man yeah this has been
superbly helpful thanks uh rich and and
and the gang thank you love your show
and uh i'm gonna keep listening thanks a
lot appreciate it thanks man hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you